Germany has confirmed that when the Iran
Fiasco was going down Donald Trump
threatened Europe with an absolutely
bonkers 25% tariff on European cars and
the goal of this was to force Europe to
start proceedings against Iran for
violating the nuclear deal which of
course they only decided to do after
Donald Trump already had pulled the
United States from that deal without
Iran having violated it in any way and
this really is going to require sort of
a multi-level analysis to unwind every
absolutely ridiculous and embarrassing
aspect of this so at first this was
merely an allegation by the supposedly
fake news Amazon Jeff Bezos Washington
Post and it just so happens that it's
been confirmed as really good reporting
the claim in the Washington Post was
that Donald Trump secretly warned France
and Germany and the United Kingdom that
the United States would impose a 25%
tariff on European cars if those
countries if Europe didn't trigger the
dispute settlement process contained in
the Iran nuclear agreement the German
Defense Minister Anna gret cramp
Karen Bauer said in London that quote
the this expression or threat as you
will does exist it was indeed a threat
that Donald Trump made trumpets are
pretending that everything's fine and
they're actually defending Donald Trump
saying it worked because Europe
reportedly is now triggering the dispute
mechanism contained in that deal except
that every European country is saying
that they had already made that decision
before Donald Trump issued this threat
and it had nothing to do with Donald
Trump's threat whatsoever so there's a
few stories here and I want to take time
to go through each of them first of all
it is Donald Trump who ruined the Iran
nuclear deal Iran is now admitting
they're enriching uranium beyond the
limits of the 2015 deal and why wouldn't
they
it's the correct game theory move if you
game this out Trump bails on the deal
starting to enrich uranium gives them
more negotiation leverage in the future
and again it's Donald Trump who bailed
on the deal anyway Donald Trump then
assassinating the Iranian
kudos leader Kasim Soleimani cemented
Iran's decision to scale-up nuclear
development number two
Trump is wildly and brazenly threatening
our allies with leverage that he
actually doesn't have here that's what's
really important to understand he
doesn't have the leverage as he is
increasingly the laughingstock
geopolitically and of European US
foreign policy and the number three and
this is really important why would
anyone get into any agreement with the
United States in good faith when Donald
Trump sometimes backs out of deals even
when the other country has stuck to its
part has done its its part to stay in
the deal to stay in compliance with the
deal and otherwise will randomly
threaten tariffs for unrelated requests
if you're another country and the US
says let's do a deal let's do a trade
deal let's do a nuclear deal that lets
do a joint defense deal whatever but
then the next president comes into the
United States Oval Office says you know
I didn't like what that last person did
and cancels the deal why do you take
deal seriously why do you even get into
deals in the first place when you have
all sorts of deals with the United
States and then the United States
randomly threatens you with the 25
percent tariff because they want you to
persecute another country why even
bother why would you see the United
States as a credible participant in
deals you wouldn't and the United States
increasingly is not seen as credible
this is how little kids work and even
little kids there's actually been
interesting studies done where little
kids seem to have a very they have a
sense of fairness that I don't want to
say is innate but very early on in
childhood they exhibit a sense of
understanding of what fairness means
they seem to exhibit more of that sense
than Donald Trump seems to exhibit and
then never mind that because once again
Donald Trump is threatening to punish
Europe with tariffs whose cost would not
be borne by Europe the cost would be
born here in the United States notice by
the way that for Donald Trump tariffs
are Trump's hammer and so everything
looks like a nail it's the only tool
Trump has to use an analogy someone told
Donald Trump about tariffs early on in
his campaign
remember when he was running on I
understand trade only I can fix it and
tariffs are the only tool that Donald
Trump has and he threatens to use that
tool everywhere like a hammer would be
used everything looking like a nail when
that's the only tool that you have
whether it's with China for economic
reasons whether it's with Europe here
for foreign policy reasons I guess
tariffs and maybe the occasional bomb or
assassination better said are the tools
that Donald Trump has it's all backwards
it's it's completely farcical universe
that we're living in Trump virus
violates the Iran nuclear deal sanctions
Iran threatens Europe to get them to do
more to Iran Europe wants no part of the
bigger picture even though on the
mechanism they had already decided to
trigger that and we once again are the
laughingstock with the leaders of other
countries talking among themselves about
did you see this crazy thing that Donald
Trump did as this is business as usual
now in the United States it's an
embarrassing moment to be led by the
person that is in the Oval Office now
hopefully we can get back to a more sort
of rational and thoughtful approach to
these issues after Donald Trump is gone
but removing Donald Trump is merely step
one in this process and you know the
early in Trump's presidency I would say
a lot of the things that he's doing can
be very quickly undone a lot of these
symbolic executive orders can be
immediately cancelled by the next
president some of the policy stuff can
be pretty quickly undone by the next
president we are now in the realm of
this stuff will take a long time to fix
removing Trump is only one part of it
we're talking of course of the
relationships with other countries that
Donald Trump has ruined and the
credibility that's been lost behind the
scenes we might think well you just
change the president and all that stuff
gets fixed no because there's a
trickle-down effect from Trump to the
diplomatic relationships where a lot of
the foreign policy is actually done a
lot of the foreign pop by the time Trump
talks to another world leader a lot of
the negotiation and the foreign policy
work has been done by the diplomats the
diplomats from the State Department and
the diplomats from other countries the
relationship
that Donald Trump is ruining
trickle-down and effectively matic
relations at many levels and it's going
to take a very long time for that to be
undone and fixed even when Donald Trump
is gone I won't go into this again
because we've talked about it before but
then you've got judges in the judiciary
it continues I mean even now while we
are looking at the impeachment Senate
trial Donald Trump looking at making
bribery legal I'll talk about that later
on in the show Donald Trump calling his
generals dopes and babies I'll talk
about that later we're talking about all
of these big embarrassments meanwhile
and we're continuing to cover it the
judges continue to be to be just swept
in often to lifetime positions certainly
to affect American jurisprudence for
decades to come
and that is not going that's not even an
issue of we've got to get Trump out to
undo it it's we've got to get Trump out
and then we need to wait a long time for
these folks to retire or die and then we
are going to have another shot at
filling a lot of these judge judgeship
so it's a disaster we are covering it
we'll continue to cover it but
importantly step one is an important one
removing Donald Trump from office but it
is only step one is what I want to
convey to you today